delighted today to be introducing colin
coleman colin is a partnered goldman
sachs where he's been head of the south
african office since 2000 in the 2008 he
was named head of the investment banking
division for sub-saharan africa in 1996
coleman was nominated as one of the
World Economic Forum global leaders of
tomorrow he's also a recipient of a in a
wood from a business school to the north
of here called business statesman award
in 1994 and he was named as one of euro
money's world top 10 financing centers
for the 21st century those are all
remarkable enough achievements but
Coleman has other arrows in his quiver
in the early 1980s Colin was a student
leader and underground member of the
African National Congress he
subsequently became involved in South
Africa's change process and later in its
constitutional transition from nineteen
eighty nine until south africa's first
democratic elections in 1994 he was an
executive director of something called
the consultative business movement which
was a very important facilitating
instrument in the transition about which
I think we might hear a little bit more
today Colin served in working groups of
the multi-party talks facilitated the
international mediation forum and helped
to negotiate the agreement to facilitate
all party participations in South
Africa's 1994 founding elections a
number of people are close to the
process have identified him to me as one
of the single most important
behind-the-scenes facilitators of the
transition so today we're hoping to get
a few insights from Colin about South
Africans transition from apartheid to
democracy in the nineteen nineties and
the challenges that it faces today the
title he's chosen for his luxury south
africa how it when its freedom and what
it's doing with its what it's doing with
it now
I'm pleased to introduce Colin Coleman
what's an absolute pleasure to be at
Yale my first visit to this esteemed
University and it's probably a good
place to start within a university
environment to talk about education and
let me read to you two quotes that I
think capsulate encapsulate the start of
my adult career in South Africa what I
faced when I was 18 years old in
thinking about the South Africa I their
new the following is the quote from
Hendrik Verwoerd prime minister of South
Africa from nineteen fifty eight to
nineteen sixty-six he said there is no
place for bunt for the bun to meaning
the African people in the European
community above certain forms of Labor
what is the use of teaching the bun to
child mathematics when it cannot use it
in practice that is quite absurd
education must train people in
accordance with their opportunities in
life according to the sphere in which
they live that was Henrik for would a
fellow student organization when I was a
student leader in something called the
National Union of South African students
was a young student organization called
kosis the Congress of South African
students and this was their reply in
1984 the education we receive is meant
to keep the South African people apart
from one another to breed suspicion
hatred and violence and to keep us
backward education is formulated so so
as to reproduce the society of racism
and exploitation and this is the world
in which I grew up it is easy to forget
where we've come from and so when today
in 2013 we think about what South Africa
has evolved into and we have certain
views which are very current it's good
to look back and think about where we've
come from and so quickly let me just
remind you of the brutality of the
apartheid system and the repression of
the years in which I was a student so I
was ave its student from 1981 to 1988
and my father he was a Human Rights
Commissioner later and a founder of the
detainees Parent Support Committee after
my brother was detained for six months
in solitary confinement in 1981 wrote a
book called crime against humanity in
which he records the following
statistics about what was called South
Africa's total strategy of repression so
between 1960 and 1990 there were 80
thousand detentions in South Africa of
which 15,000 were children under the age
of 18 and 10,000 were woman of those
80,000 an estimated twenty thousand were
tortured and three thousand were banned
there were political trials involving a
hundred and fifty thousand people in
this period and ten thousand
publications were banned there were in
the period nineteen forty eight to
nineteen eighty-three 1400 deaths in
political unrest and from 1984 to 1989
5,000 people lost their lives of those
in extra legal assassinations
disappearances and abductions 218
activists were killed today I have a
scholarship that I fund called the Becky
Emlyn Guinea scholarship for human
rights at the University of law of at
the University of advisors front in the
Faculty of Law and that's in the name of
Becky Emlyn Guinea who was in one of the
activists who was assassinated through
the detonation of a
walkman headphone when he switched it on
which was proven to have been placed by
the security police this was the South
Africa that we knew in the 1980s and we
live through so the question is how did
South Africa when its freedom from this
very violent past with a system that was
brutal and unforgiving and racists and
racist well there really are three
things that if I had to lift out of the
experiences that we lived through in
those times that i would say
characterize South Africa's transition
and from which we can learn the first
was the mass mobilization and popular
revolt which was led by the African
National Congress and its allies in the
pre-1994 period and it's absolutely
important and vital for everything that
goes before to say that you know it was
really the African masses across the
country not only Soweto in 1976 but
right throughout the country and right
right throughout the periods if you
study it that created an environment of
resistance to apartheid and through the
counter resistance and repression of the
state an incredible amount of conflict
and tension that arose but this was a
backdrop to other factors the second
issue that I wanted to read it to really
crystallized out was the role of civil
society through this period and the fact
is the churches led by the South African
council of churches as one example
business and ian has mentioned the
consultative business movement labour in
the form of cassato and other trade
union leaders that and organizations
that evolved and the communities which
is really galvanized in the mid 90s by
the United Democratic Front these were
the church business labor community
organizations that really formed the
civil society backdrop to the mass
protests that were taking place and
really provided a huge amount of
leverage and leadership to ensuring that
there was a transition that the the
whole society evolved through this
period of mass mobilization and
repression that was taking place and
then in the midst of this were the
leaders and the leadership provided by
Nelson Mandela and the anc x fw de klerk
and the national party at certain points
and in the end by Chief Berta Lizzy at
from the ifp all we provided different
roles but effectively what I've come to
learn is that in societies of trial
change there's a very strong dialectic
between the mass mobilization that's
taking place and the decisions made by
leaders at critical points in time and I
think it's important before I give you
an example to recognize how close South
Africa was to a full civil war
effectively April 27 1994 will go down
as the day South Africa held its
peaceful democratic elections in the
transition from apartheid to democracy
as the critical moment and was followed
by the election of Nelson Mandela as the
first president on April in in May 1994
but the fact is that in the weeks
leading up to the selection of April 27
1994 South Africa was the bricks of an
apocalypse and that was at the very time
that in Rwanda 1 million people lost
their lives and it was as close to that
in South Africa that we were literally
days and weeks away from that sort of
catastrophe and when you think back to
this what was the difference the
difference was civil society on the back
of the mass mobilization working
together with leaders
to make the right decisions at the
critical moments just in time and when I
talk about this having been at the
coalface of the negotiation process at
that time and gone through first a
failed attempt with dr. Henry Kissinger
at international mediation on behalf of
the African National Congress and in
Carter freedom party where I was as the
consultative business movement executive
director at the time responsible for
attempting to bring this mediation to
fruit and with without boring you with
the detail of it we were unable to get
the parties at the end to agree the
terms of the mediation and so dr.
Kissinger and the mediators that were
with him including Lord Carrington left
the country and at that point in time we
thought that in Carter Freedom Party was
going to effectively have to go headlong
into war with the rest of the country
post the elections having been left out
of the elections and we knew that there
was very significant potential for
violence and we were informed by the
security forces and the Independent
Election Commission that South Africa
without in Carter in the election was
very Paris Lee close to a very very
dangerous moment and through
negotiations and facilitation that one
of the mediators who stay behind
Washington akuma and myself managed to
to to undertake 10 days before the April
27th elections we effectively managed in
the last in three days of negotiation to
persuade firstly chief machida lazy to
participate in the election looking down
the barrel of effective being left out
and potentially facing the consequences
of being isolated outside of the
election process left out of the
government of national unity and finding
himself in the wilderness
and persuading him that he should he was
better off to be in the election process
and in the government then outside the
process and through that you know
finding out what his demands were and
finding a way to get those demands
incorporate and they were quite simple
one was that he was able to participate
in the election to that there would be
post-election international mediation on
some of the constitutional issues that
had become problematic and third that
the sovereignty of the Zulu kingdom
would be enshrined in the Constitution
and with that basic agreement although
very difficult to execute and negotiate
we then set about in those days
negotiating with mr. Mandela and mr. de
Klerk and I mentioned this example
because it is the example I was most
close to and which I will always
remember that shows how leaders actually
make the difference between victory and
defeat for a whole country and what mr.
Mandela did when he was faced with this
option for including mr. but lazy in the
election process was not short of
remarkable because what he did was
effectively instructed his political
support base and leadership to negotiate
these points he found mr. de Klerk who
in turn made it possible for the in
cotton freedom party to become part of
the elections through taking taking a
sticker below the bottom party which
happened to be the National Party which
was a strategic point on the ballot
paper and allowing that sticker to be
placed at the bottom of the ballot paper
which was a major concession politically
for him and and agreeing to post into a
post-election international mediation
but effectively without having much time
to share with you the detail these are
some of the examples that make the
difference between
you know a country succeeding and a
country being defeated and the fact that
business civil society and the political
leaders trusted each other hand had
vehicles in place to communicate
effectively at such a critical moment
was part of the reason why we were able
to get to a peaceful election yes some
people think this was a miracle that
took place but in fact when you look at
the detail and unpack it we lived it
there was no miracle from above we made
it happen and we made it happen because
the leaders made it happen because the
society made it happen and because we
had in place the processes to make it
happen so the question arises what have
we done with this piece that we want and
so since 94 till now let me share with
you some of the statistics because South
Africa is a far way away from you at
Yale University and so let me share with
you how i see it in 98 from 1982 1993 is
14 years the next 14 from 94 to 2007 and
then five years from 2008 to 2012 so in
the 14 years from 1982 1993 South
Africa's GDP growth rate was one point
four percent from 94 to 2007 it became
three-point-six percent and you could
see the peace dividend over that
extended 14 years is an extensive pick
up in the growth rate and obviously post
the financial crisis in 2007 the 2008 to
2012 period declined the growth rate but
was still significantly better than the
14 years from 1982 1993 and we had a
growth rate in those five years of
two-point-three percent the inflation
rate in the first 14-year period was
fourteen point two percent and in the
nineteen years since has fallen to
around six and a half percent the
commercial lending rate went from seven
point three percent in that 14 year
period from 1982 1993 to a recent
five-year period of ten percent and so
you see that the peace dividend from the
fiscal and monetary discipline of the
government in the post 94 period has
paid off handsomely and let me just give
you a snapshot of the absolute sizes of
the gdp in 1980 we had an 80 billion
dollar economy with a jet debt-to-gdp
ratio of thirty percent which grew to
135 million dollars in 94 and a debt to
GDP of forty-four percent and many
people thought that South Africa was
effectively bankrupt as Mandela took the
presidential inauguration oath in 2007
we had grown the economy to 286 billion
dollars and the debt-to-gdp ratio had
fallen from the forty four percent at
the first days of democracy to
twenty-eight percent it has since picked
up to the current around forty percent
although that's way below where many
developed countries exist today not
include not excluding the United States
so on the face of it the development of
the fiscal and monetary statistics and
framework has been very very impressive
in this period notwithstanding the
global financial crisis the one area
that has not improved is the
unemployment statistics which have
effectively gone from around twenty two
percent in 1994 to the current
twenty-five percent and that's the
formal a narrow definition of employment
of unemployment which excludes those
who've given up looking for a job and if
you include that it's actually more like
forty three percent and poverty to
statistics remain very high very high
however against that backdrop there's a
very interesting development which I
want to immediately share with you and
that is if you look at just the period
2001 to 2010 for example the ls m's the
category of income
that are measured has moved from the the
higher income levels of lsm five to ten
increasing from 13.7 million people to
23 and a half million people in that
period that's moving from 47% to
sixty-nine percent of the population
going up the lsm definition and so in
essence the lower l SMS the first five
LS M's lost 4.6 million people so in
other words 4.6 million people left the
definition of the lower income groups
and in that period of 10 years the lsm
526 added 5 million the lsm seven at 1.7
million and the top lsm band of 8 to 10
added 3 million people for a total
increase of the lsm 5 to 10 category to
just short of 10 million people in other
words 1 million people per year
effectively came into the higher lsm
brackets which is very very impressive
and so you may ask how is that possible
that this occurred in there really three
factors the first is the Social Welfare
grants that 15 million people in South
Africa out of 51 million are now living
on Social Welfare grants of the state
number one number two the state has been
very systemic lee building universal
access and funding universal access in
the form of housing electrification
telecommunications and other social
services and lastly real incomes of
people through employment axis of the
formerly disadvantaged and
disenfranchised African people into the
mainstream of the economy has added real
incomes to the to the economic
environment and so that tells a very
very significant story with the main
sticking point remaining unemployment
unemployment is very difficult to define
and measure because the informal economy
you must remember is often not recorded
statistically and so whilst the current
census should capture much of it some
people think the real unemployment rate
is lower than the official 25% having
said that there's no doubt that
unemployment and poverty remains and the
gini coefficient being high remains the
biggest challenge of the current
administration so in closing when we
think about what South Africa is doing
with the freedom that it's one I would
categorize two basic phases first is
what I call em Becky and Mandela era
which is both president Mbeki and
President Mandela's time from 94 to 2007
in which there was a very competent very
successful administration President
Mandela led an error in his term of
office of reconciliation which included
the truth truth and reconciliation
commission dealing with much of the
brutality that I referred to earlier in
the repression of political resistance
thirdly the fiscal and monetary
discipline that we saw under the
successive governments of the ANC and
lastly a subterranean political contest
within the NC that was taking place at
the time that ultimately unseated
president and Becky the second era was
the post polokwane II era which I call
from Paula kwani to mang juan pollo
quani was the 2007 anc conference at
which President Zuma was elected and led
to the fall of President Mbeki a year
later and the appointment of President
Zuma one year later than that and
maguann was the the last ANC conference
in which a new leadership emerged with
President Zuma and seroma poza an old
anc leader from the constitutional
negotiate
asians who is a highly respected
businessman who is coming to the fore
and many people ask whether his
rejoining the ANC leadership in this
manner is going to change the picture in
the post Zuma error but there's various
things that really dominate this polar
coordinate among guang guang area one is
obviously the global financial crisis
and its effects and obviously in the
emerging markets the global financial
crisis did impact countries like South
Africa and effectively we lost 1 million
employment jobs in that period
immediately post-2008 secondly a
contestation of the union movement with
the Marikana events the tragic Marikana
events being the focal point of that
catalytic moment in which it appears
that the Casati union and national union
of mineworkers and a new union that is
arisen of fighting for dominance of the
mining sector and that is ongoing and
then ongoing tensions within the African
National Congress and its alliance in
summary today where are we yes we have
many challenges and the challenges that
we have today are fundamentally
different from the challenges I started
off addressing in which in 1980s South
Africa was deeply divided and
potentially at war with itself the
challenges today are ones of ongoing
unemployment and poverty of corruption
in various levels of the government of
poor administration and a consumptive
state which is largely failing in its
ability to be productive and that is
best seen in the education and health
sector where we have amongst the best
investment in education and health
amongst emerging markets were one of the
poorest outputs in terms of measurement
of life
expectancy or literacy or other measures
of education and health infrastructure
bottlenecks that continue to plague the
capacity of the South African economy
and its ability to grow and ongoing
crime and social violence that has been
witnessed of late the opportunity is
side of the balance sheet is however as
interesting and as compelling firstly
Africa has become a very very
interesting neighborhood and certainly
by comparison with the no growth of
Europe many investors are looking at
Africa as a five percent plus growth
economy and growth opportunity with a
billion people and looking at various
investment opportunities and that leads
me to the second and major factor which
is China I personally was the architect
of something which was the largest
investment outside of China ever at that
point and that was the investment by
icbc today the largest bank in the world
into standard bank for five and a half
billion dollars just post the meeting of
African leaders in Beijing in 2006 I
went over to Beijing and we have we we
we basically introduced the idea of
investing to in Africa too many players
and icbc became very intrigued and
interested in it led to effectively this
transaction in which they bought this
five and a half billion dollars twenty
percent stake in standard bank and that
was the first of many transactions that
have since taken place in the mining
sector in the health sector in various
other oil sector and so on in which I
personally been involved but many others
have been involved and this Africa China
relationship is I would venture to say
not opportunistic it is structural and
systemic and one that we're going to
live with for decades to come and I'm
happy to talk about that in some more
detail
the third opportunity is obviously the
capital markets and the strength and
sophistication of the economy the fact
that South African companies and many of
them like MTN and Standard Bank and
other companies are becoming the
champions of growth in Africa as a whole
and are investing and growing day by day
the infrastructure of the African
continent if you take the shoprite
example they are building properties in
many countries throughout Africa that
don't exist and building the
infrastructure for South Africa's and
Africa's consumer revolution civil
society continues to play an absolutely
critical role and I believe will be
amongst the major countervailing issues
when it comes to exposing corruption and
exposing weak administration leadership
remains extremely deep and strong in
South Africa and that is I think a great
opportunity going forward to ensure that
that leadership rises to the surface and
helps and of course finally the basic
architecture that we were able to put in
place in 94 a free press a world-class
modern Constitution and a judiciary that
remains strong as ever and other
institutions such as the south african
reserve bank the competition commission
and other institutions of the
constitution that remain very robust and
independent and forces for good and so
that's the reality we have today an
unfinished story a story that on the one
hand we can be extremely proud as a
nation that we have overcome enormous
difficulties that is easy to forget but
yet today we still face difficulties
just of a different type whether with
the leadership that's in place a strong
society a strong economy and a civil
society that will keep the leaders on
their toes thanks very much
I thank you colin would you like to
field your own questions or shall I any
comments questions yes sir can you speak
a little louder
look at three is I'm not really in a
position to talk about the Arab
countries because I don't know them well
enough and one of the lessons that I
would share with you is that you have to
really understand that the detail and
richness and the fabric of the society
is you're dealing with otherwise you
cannot lead them and you cannot
facilitate or engage or negotiate with
countries that you don't really finally
understand so I do agree that leadership
is critical I mean when I look and I
again I don't know all that much about
the Palestinian conflict for example but
it strikes me that with President Bill
Clinton there was and and president
Arafat there was a huge opportunity that
was missed that I'm not sure we'll see
again in our lifetimes to resolve the
Palestinian conflict at that moment and
that was certainly down to leadership
and President Clinton's obvious great
leadership at that point in time offered
the Palestinians and opportunity which
unfortunately slipped through the hands
and the question is why did it slip
through the hands there wasn't it would
seem to me from the outside there wasn't
a mass environment which made it
impossible but the leadership didn't
take that opportunity and perhaps in
that is a lesson about the ongoing Arab
Spring I think the truth is the Arab
Spring is in many senses of spontaneous
spontaneous uprising and which the
leaders are going to emerge I don't
think the story has been told whether
the leaders are there or they yet to
emerge but it seems to be a very fluid
situation and I hope that you know those
leaders do emerge and not that you know
we look back in 20 years time and and
and look upon it as chaos but I must say
dr. Kissinger once told me a story in
which he went to see Chairman Mao and
and chairman mao apparently answered a
question from dr. Kissinger who said to
him while they were waiting for a
meeting to start Chairman Mao what do
you think
of the French Revolution and Chairman
Mao said it's far too early to say so it
does seem to me it's too early to say
it's a very good question it's commonly
referred to as black economic
empowerment and the question is has it
been a experiment that people have
regretted or people have endorsed and
what's the view of it today and I think
the I think the the the need for black
economic empowerment in the economy was
absolutely undoubted I think that at the
point of Mandela President Mandela
coming into office something like ninety
percent if not ninety-five percent of
the economy was in the hands of ten
companies at that point in time and in
almost all of those companies were all
of their board of directors will white
male and so today you have seen the
evolution of a very significant
transformation of the economy but at the
same time many of my compatriots in
South Africa would say that it's far
it's far too insufficient to say that
there has been a transformation of the
economy they're two aspects to it the
one is the racial or the D
rationalization of the economy and then
the second aspect is how much the power
structures of the economy have changed
and effectively on the latter one can
only really see the power structures of
the economy changing in the public
sector because that is where the
government is appointing its own people
and the truth is I think that we have
very much say in the mining industry the
same
katek chur in the mining sector that we
did in 94 and that is at the Maracana
events being one of the focuses of
criticism not just of the way the police
handled the matter of the way the unions
handled the matter but also the nature
of the system the mining system in South
Africa being effectively much as it has
been since time immemorial and so yes
there are phases there's been d
racialization of many of the boards
there's been economic ownership
transferred and there's been an attempt
by the government through the mining
charter and other charters in different
sectors to incentivize and structure
that there has been a transformation
towards black economic ownership of the
economy so there has been progress but
it has been uncertain probably
insufficient but directionally I would
say it's gone in the right direction
okay the youth wage subsidy is an
ongoing debate the youth wage subsidy is
a subsidy from the government as far as
I understand it in the tax roll it's a
tax deduction or it's it's an income
deduction before taxes for that has been
proposed by the government as a way of
alleviating youth unemployment it's an
incentive to business to hire youth as
defined further criteria and the law and
an incentive to to hire them and train
them for employment and different
parties have different views on the
nature of it safe to say that the trade
union movement is actually against the
youth subsidy as a form of structurally
changing the employment situation
everybody's trying to deal with how do
you train how do you incentivize the
unemployed and there's roughly a million
people coming into the labor market
every year and we're creating less than
a million jobs a year and so this is the
dynamic it's deeply troubling and it
really is a question of what is the
structure of the economy and how do we
create jobs in the South African economy
and that's at the heart of the debate
Africa is an exciting investment
opportunity Africa in what ways is it
useful and what ways and misleading to
talk about the continent
as this homogenous opportunity because a
lot of the coverage these days doesn't
even attempt to distinguish between
different markets so how do you see that
plan there is a first the point of
celebration that we are talking about
Africa as an opportunity rather than the
CNN version of Africa as a rolling
disaster and so we should celebrate that
but it's absolutely true when you dig
into it Africa's many different places
there's the oil countries the welcome
generating countries that all consuming
countries with 53 countries in Africa
but really there are I would say three
or four countries that are really going
to lead the pack and those countries
include South Africa and gola Nigeria
and Egypt and again that comes back to
the Arab Spring how the North African
environment works out will be important
I would say outside of South Africa
Nigeria is a single most important
country and I visit there a lot it's 150
million people a slightly smaller
economy about 250 300 billion dollar GDP
relative to South Africa's 400 but it's
growing at seven percent eight percent
per annum a GDP growth with enormous oil
resources two million barrels of oil a
day and so if it does the right things
just the right basic things it doesn't
do wrong things and it does very basic
reforms like investing in power
generation capacity which would unleash
economic economic growth potential in
the economy you will see Nigeria as a
very big story outstripping South Africa
maybe not this year or next but in the
next few years nigeria will be the
biggest economy in the continent and
growing of that huge demographic in a
very very exciting way the fact is that
many of these countries there are two
real underlying problems one is
corruption which is endemic in many
countries but two is really the
institutional skills in the government's
and the capacity to administer you know
the depart
ments and and those economies in an
efficient way and if they deal with
those two questions and obviously the
World Bank and various other
institutions are doing everything they
can to Train skilled people in Africa
and to put the right people in place you
know if we deal with those two questions
I think Africa will see a rapid rise
from a very low base you must remember
today but a very exciting rise in terms
of growth and development
so I think there's two questions the
corruption is not you know it's not a
police issue it's it's really an issue
across all sectors in South Africa and
really I mean corruption in in it's sort
of academic analytical sense is a
contest over resources and distribution
of resources in an extra legal manner
and you know in a in a resource in a
resource Hungary environment corruption
is going to tend to be greater and so
the fact is that you know we have to you
know we have to really modernize the
administration we have to put watchdogs
in place why I mentioned you know the
press civil society and others is
because that's the best means through
which we expose and shame corruption and
ensure that the political parties who
you know Harbor corruption know that
that will not be tolerated by the
populace and deal with it and so you
know there's a there's the truth is a
contest going on for power for riches
for resources and for society wanting
that to be done in a in a correct way
and that will unfold the police i think
is a more special case and it feels to
me like it's less a problem the police
force of bad intentions than just poor
management and I you know I think that
the there have been various ways in
which the military the security
apparatus the police force since the
apartheid years has been transformed
obviously just as in the economy we had
to derail eyes the institutions of state
and through the D racialization there's
been an accretion of skills and Anna
lack and and a loss of skills in certain
places
that is uneven and through the
transformation politically also from
them back into the zoom administration
there's been changes in the leadership
structures of many institutions
including the police and some of those
changes have been better and some of
those changes of not being so good and
so you know I think at the end of it
there is both a question of leadership
and management and hopefully there will
be attempts to get the leadership and
the management of the police force to
erase these you know attention-grabbing
headline shots that we have of some poor
Muslim beacon who parked on the wrong
side of the road getting you know hauled
by the police into a truck and then
dying after you know some pretty brutal
attacks on him which have no place in in
a modern civilized economy in country
like South Africa and is really
horrified many people so the maricón
events that event the dealings with you
know events like Oscars pretorius
pistorius's girlfriend getting killed
these have not been good headlines for
the country but you know when you look
back what I'm trying to sort of say is
when you contextualize the last 50 years
of where we come from and the violence
that there was I was saying to Ian
Shapiro you know in the in the post
April 94 period violence stopped from
something between a hundred and seven
hundred deaths per month in South Africa
to under 50 and today there is really no
real systemic political deaths going on
so that you've got to also dis situate
the progress that is made even though
anyone death is unacceptable you know
the Constitution
however last year the government were
funded a rather substantial effort to
curb the press and threaten the
Independence of the courts yeah look
again you know this is part of the
political contest that is taking place
and so you know again civil society
played a very loud an important role
including the business organizations in
appealing to Parliament and also various
sections of the liberation the old
liberation movement itself being unhappy
and being vocal about not wanting those
amendments to the secrecy bill or other
forms of attacks on the Constitution
attempts for example to change the
boundaries in that was set up in the
Constitution through careful
negotiations various attempts to change
the constitutional framework that have
failed there has not yet been a single
successful attack on the constitutional
principles that I'm aware of anyway at
this point in time and that's because
there is a very robust process of
engagement that doesn't mean to say
there aren't people who are for vested
interest purposes trying very hard to
narrow the constitutional principles or
to change you know things like the
freedom of the press for their own
purposes but so far they've not been
successful
louder you talked about some of the
challenging your face on Africa right
now and while I think a lot of markings
are related I think the defining
challenge now is fixing what some would
call a broken communication public
communication system I think given that
South Africans where it's at in terms of
its economic position in Africa that's a
shame it's a disgrace that our public
education system is so behind a lot of
that so I guess my question is what what
is the government doing what's currently
happening let me say I think this is
captured by the following and the many
people who think that the definition of
unemployment is what i said earlier but
the question is about whether people are
employable not so much just unemployed
and the fact is south africa's short
skills in a country where there's huge
unemployment and so the question is why
are many people unemployable and it does
come down to the nature of the education
system and there's no question the
education system is far too weak and you
know the nature of the of the Graduate
graduates that are coming through the
schooling system into the education
system is very very weak and when you
look at the underlying reasons for this
the fact is that we are living with the
generations that I i started with from
Hendrik Verwoerd where you know
effectively many of the teachers that
are teaching the kids of today were
brought up under a system where he did
not want to teach them mathematics and
they didn't teach it they were very
successful they didn't teach people the
skills needed for a modern society and
these are the people now teaching the
students of today so how does a lost
generation get a found generation
and this is a real problem so the fact
is the government I think is doing a lot
of what is required but failing in many
instances to just do the basic right
things and so when you read that
President Zuma has attempted to
articulate that education should be
deemed an essential service that is code
effectively for saying that the teachers
and those who are in the essential
service should not be allowed to strike
should not be allowed not to attend
schools for so-called political reasons
or for labor reasons and what is going
on is that when you look under the
surface at the data many of the
principles are not coming to school many
of the teachers are absent many of the
teachers are illiterate and so the
nature of the education system has to be
radically transformed and cleansed but
it's very difficult because these
teachers and the education employees are
some of the constituents that are voting
zuma into office so there's a political
contest over the education resources in
the country and so this is a very you
know dynamic process it sort of reminds
me you know this Gil scott-heron song
you know the teller the revolution will
be alive it won't be televised you know
if you if you if you remember what he
said you know revolutions are not
straightforward linear things there are
battles of real situations and so you
know the education system i agree is a
big focus in the focus of many people
but i don't think it's going to be a
quick fix
sub-saharan Africa what you're worried
about civil society
with how would you compare the magic of
3d experience in South Africa with that
it saves in Bob way which had an
infrastructure of
vs. and go lunch a little bit structure
but it's very resource-rich is now
attention
what was the magic ingredient to get a
civil society
you seem very well informed one Angola
and Zimbabwe I think I think the the key
difference which hopefully came out
through the talker gave is that
effectively Angola and Zimbabwe were
military revolutions they were the
contest in the this power struggle was
defined in the military sense whereas in
South Africa was a political transition
it was less about a military transition
and by which I mean there was a victor
and a vanquished in the sort of colonial
sense in both Angolan Zimbabwe and so
there was no real civil society in
either Angola or Zimbabwe that could
deal with the pre and the post
liberation dynamics where as in South
Africa as I explained you know the whole
society was part of the solution and the
nature of the transition and the
settlement was in fact a political
settlement not a military settlement so
in Zimbabwe you know you effectively
have a political class that was the
military zana PF people that were were
Victor's in ism in the Zimbabwe
revolution that inherited the political
power and they created you know a grip
on the resources of the country the
farms and so on and so forth and
effectively Mugabe was you know the
spearhead of the land grabs and the
various things which he did in the name
of contesting the fairness of lancaster
house and the talks at lancaster house
in angola effectively the post defeat of
you need to landed the landfill emo and
so he landed the mpla in a position of
you know unfettered power and they are
the people who control the economy
totally
in Angola today but the fact is there is
you know a huge amount of resources in
Angola amongst very few people there 16
million people in Angola it's also 2
million barrel of oil a day economy and
so it's much easier to distribute even
if there's a high degree of corruption
in that society to distribute the
resources and there's a massive rise if
you visit Luanda you can just feel the
money pumping through the veins of that
economy and yes maybe man of much of it
is corrupt but somehow it's distributed
through the society and you could feel
it when you visit whereas in Zimbabwe
it's very much held in the political
elite
well I think that this is one of those
sort of lasting legacies of president
and Becky is you know his manner of
dealing with the zimbabwe situation
meant that in effect we not only
inherited Zimbabwe's problems we
inherited Zimbabwe's people and so I
think if i'm not mistaken some people
think that there's about five million
Zimbabweans in South Africa today which
is very significant percent it's ten
percent of south africa's population
being zimbabweans and it's very visible
and these are largely educated people
you know immigrants with initiative and
so you know the relative education the
relative initiative seen against the
context of African South African
unemployment you could see the reasons
why xenophobia and contest and
competition arise between relatively
well educated now employed zimbabweans
and unemployed uneducated South Africans
without putting too crude a point on it
that is the cause of a lot of that
structural tension which is inflamed by
ethnic tensions in the society and that
is a factor now there is in a phobia
that we saw which was very vivid some
years ago has not to my knowledge been
repeated but there's been lots of fear
that that structural dynamic will blow
up again and reports of various you know
less visible manifestations of that in
terms of people being chased out of
their communities and so on and so forth
but it's definitely a big factor that's
underlying and
the fact is that many of these
immigrants are playing a normal role in
South African society or not you know
accepted as such would you say more
about how you see China's agenda in
Africa and how dependent that after
renée's on skis on that and particularly
not only South Africa and how it effects
of Africa situations with yesterday okay
well let me just say I think the you
know the nature of the brickz Alliance
is really a political alliance South
Africa is a much smaller economy than
any of its counterparts within the BRICS
Brazil Russia India and China but it's
it's a it's a good point because at the
end of this month in March the presence
of Russia Brazil India and China will be
in South Africa with President Zuma and
I'll be attending the business summit of
that session in Durban and you know the
fact is that these meetings where it is
institutionalization of the relationship
between these countries for example they
are talking about the creation of a
BRICS Development Bank and you know in
which the savings of all of those
countries will be pooled and savings
will be mobilized for development
purposes between the bricks economies is
a it's a meaningful alliance and one
that has potential long-term
implications China specifically I think
has a systemic view of Africa for the
following reasons China's long-term
future in terms of growth depends on
commodities not just of the mineral type
commodities like copper and and other
inputs into the economy and the building
of China but also food Africa has sixty
percent of the world's arable and
uncultivated land and so from a food
production point of view in Angola is
one of the main countries that are rich
in error
uncultivated resources you know that is
going to attract a lot of interest and
is attracting a lot of interest in terms
of capital mobilization in terms of
resource mobilization and so China has
created a variety of agreements for
example one agreement is a nine billion
dollar copper for capital loan that has
been struck with the DRC which was
actually approved after some amendments
by the World Bank and IMF and China has
dispersed nine billion dollars to the
DRC which is twice its annual budget so
it's not exactly going to turn down nine
billion dollars and say thank you we
morally want to defend our sovereignty
thank you very much they're going to say
thanks very much we're going to try and
get what we can for it and by the way
the copper that is now being generated
from the ground through the
infrastructure investment would not not
otherwise be produced and so China is
playing a role in liberating the
resources of Africa for its own reasons
and purposes and Africa is trying to
find the balance of how it gets what it
needs from the negotiations with China
and frankly from my experience with the
Chinese the Chinese want to do the right
thing sometimes you know they don't
necessarily know how to get to that
solution but they are not you know this
is not the Scramble for Africa part two
after the colonial scramble in which
they are just going to rape and exploit
African resources for Chinese game
they're going to try and do it in the
best way that they can and to the extent
that Africa negotiates you know
community investment resources
relationships technical and capital
transfer transfers they will do that and
China will cooperate because it wants
Africa to be successful and effectively
that's what the dynamic is but to the
extent that the African countries you
know extract
rupt you know practices or loans or
whatever you know then it's going to
work out badly for Africa so it's as
much in the hands of Africa's how this
works out the factor is a factor and
I've said in the United States before
that we can't just take a moral view of
the china-africa relationship we have to
engage with it so I was very pleased to
see for example walmart invest into
Massmart a couple of years ago as one of
the more recent instances in which the
United States have taken a or United
States interest have taken a big step
forward into the foreign direct
investment into Africa otherwise this is
going to be a one-way street between
China and Africa very large electro
dominance before in which the most
significant political struggles have NC
happened in D&C rather than
see another party's what are your
thoughts in terms of any prospects of
any type of change in that dynamic
I wouldn't say the short term but
perhaps a medium term whether through
the growth of support of other parties
or some sort of fracture here to it so I
think the latter is more probable in the
former meaning the fracturing of the ANC
if it were to happen would be more
likely to lead to change in the
structure of the politics then looking
for it to happen from outside the NC
that's the short answer the more in
detailed answer is for those who are not
aware the answer is one between 62 and
sixty-seven percent of the vote at each
election since 1994 and in fact I would
venture to suggest that in the next
election it's not going to be less and I
say that because President Zuma is very
popular and through the introduction of
ceramic posing to the leadership he is
widened the appeal of the ANC not
narrowed it and so you know the fact is
the ANC remains the most powerful
incumbent with no real contest coming
from outside now that might be
controversial that's my personal opinion
but the Democratic Alliance has
essentially remained the non-african
choice and the ANC has remained the
African choice when you look at the
statistics south africa's 51 million
people the latest census tells you 40
million of those are African and the
balance on non-african meaning white
colored or Indian under the
classifications and you know the whites
population is somewhere around five
million so it's you know to be
successful in politics in South Africa
you have to appeal to the African Votto
you just really are nowhere and so the
African National Congress is
overwhelmingly the center of the African
political preference and so the nature
the structural nature of it will be that
the ANC will be the point through which
the Preferences of the African
population will be expressed in my view
for the foreseeable future including the
me
m term and so I do not see cope for
example which was a breakaway post them
Becky defeat in the ANC had the
potential to do that because in a way it
was a break away from the NC itself and
but the fact is that it has proven post
post that to be a failed experiment and
its leaders are fighting in the courts
rather than fighting agency in
Parliament and has lost a lot of
enthusiasm the DA remains by and large
confined to the African to the white
colored in Indian community some people
think it is being successful in
penetrating into the African community
but time and 2014 will be a leveler and
I would suspect that there's not going
to be much movement you know the the
history of the ANC is so deep 100 years
old over 100 years old now with very
strong leaders and a very deep
organization and what I mentioned
earlier is the social welfare grants the
manner in which the government has
attempted to provide universal services
for those that have nothing the fact
that though that population has grown at
1 million a year outside of the pirelli
seems tells you that 1,000,000 people
are more likely to vote for those for
the for the ANC and then come and
government they're not so I'm rather
sober minded about the potential for a
for emergence of a non ANC opposition
having said that the politics the ANC
are very interesting and I would say you
know that as long as President Zuma
who's been very smart politically within
his own party is able to continue on
that path you know the nce will in all
likelihood for the medium-term maintain
its position
it's a trance or ii III don't have this
to back me up but I would be followed
when you look at the political
distribution of women in society it has
vastly transformed so I think I'm not
wrong in saying that fifty percent of
all parliamentarians a woman which is
probably the highest distribution in the
world the distribution of women amongst
the newly empowered black South Africans
in the boards of South Africa has been
pretty successful the charters have
stipulated that you get rewarded in
terms of points for the charter you get
rewarded for black economic empowerment
ownership of Africans but you also get
specific rewards for women empowerment
and so they've been many women's
empowerment groups like the woman in the
vestment portfolio peotone a variety of
these that have as women's groups gone
into the empowerment structures in
corporate South Africa so that's the
tendency towards good news the bad users
on the social front where I think the
the nature of abuse woman abused child
abuse the violence against woman has
become endemic and I think if you look
at the instances that are being reported
of rape and abuse against women
particularly in the townships of South
Africa it's pretty worrying the extent
of widespread intimidation and abuse of
women in society and it's become a real
focus and there's been a significant
outpouring and i haven't mentioned aids
at all today but i think that the you
know the story of AIDS in South Africa
is certainly one in which it's
increasingly
an African woman story and so you know
this this is the sort of split reality i
think for women in south africa that
they are politically supported and
socially they have been you know not not
been supported in the homes and in the
townships I don't think we could let you
escape without one further question that
goes to the really unique position that
you personally have had you know you've
got appropriated underground number
rings see to the head of sub-saharan
active investors / Goldman Sachs e30 via
thirty five year period and so I was
just wondering if you eat before we wrap
up you'd want to reflect on any aspect
of that personal transition but also and
I don't know how much agreed to speak
about this but of the role of Goldman in
South Southern Africa not on the in
South Africa fact talk about this these
Chinese investors that you've been part
of how do you see volgens draw in south
and south africa's confronting the sword
has to confirm and what personally you
can do to you so any piece of that you
write a lot of questions well thanks
very much for this and if it's my last
answer this to you personally thank you
again for making this possible it really
is a pleasure for me to come and an
experiment in a way to come to Yale for
me personally to share this with you and
take time out of the busy goldman sachs
schedule to share this with you and I
know that because I've asked for their
support that they do support me doing it
and I look forward to the next few days
talking to people and hopefully if you
have questions you know I'm happy to
spend some time but let me say I think
on the personal transition side look
I've been extremely fortunate I'm 50
years old and at the age of 32 I found
myself in 1994 having a choice of either
going into politics as i was asked
effectively i was named on the ANC
election list in january nineteen
ninety-four in the run-up to the
election without being asked I found my
name on the election list and I had to
call Walter Sisulu and ask him about
this and he said to me well Colin you
know politics is a risky business you
have to make up your mind about what you
want to do let me know and then I asked
a lot of people who anti-pot out leaders
about whether they thought I should go
into politics and to a person they said
you don't want to be at the age of 32 a
backbencher in Parliament and really
should you should continue doing what
you were doing which is the CBM and find
a career in business and you know later
in life you can always choose to take
that path if you want to and so you know
that was an important moment in terms of
dealing with the impact of the
transition on me personally but I
wouldn't have I mean you know at the age
of 32 I then had to decide what I wanted
to do and so you know one of the lessons
maybe four other young people
is what i did was i spoke to four people
that I really trusted that I went to
them and I said look you know what do
you think I should be doing and one of
them said to me well you need to know
that at the age of 32 you've helped make
history and you'll never have that
chance again and the best of your life
is over so please decide what it is that
makes you happy and take that path and
what I had to decide was what made me
happy and what made me happy is to be
stimulated and I don't like to be you
know on the back foot I like to be
always at the edge of what's happening
and to help the construction of society
and I felt in 94 and I think I was young
in my judgment by good and good in my
judgment that the next site of the
contribution to society's development
would be in the economy and so I thought
banking was the best place as an
architect and as an activist to then go
go do banking at the age of 32 which is
what i did so i joined standard bank and
helped advise them on what to do about
the new South Africa and then left South
Africa in 97 to go and learn merger and
acquisition technology in London with JP
Morgan for three years and then came
back for Goldman Sachs and I think there
was a very good journey it also helped
me get exposure to global institutions
and to think about life outside of South
Africa and get a more of a global
perspective and so today I think I'm in
a much better position to help South
Africa having seen the world and made
the global connections so their problem
leads into the China question which is
to me one of the most exciting things
I've done since joining Goldman Sachs in
two thousand obviously building the
business but then reading which was
really a judgment again that China was
structurally becoming interested in
Africa because when they asked 50
three leaders and presidents go to
Beijing in 2006 in November and sit with
the president of China you know they're
not doing that for fun and so I thought
that I better investigate this
phenomenon and you know invest in it and
that's been one of the best things I've
done because I do believe that china is
going to be in my lifetime the
long-range phenomenon of world growth
and when you just think about what does
it mean that in 2050 China will be twice
the size of the United States economy if
the bricks analysis is correct I've told
my my two daughters and a son that I
have only two rules for them one is
don't eat McDonald's and to you have to
learn Mandarin and so I'm very proud
that my daughter Zoe is now 14 has
started her mandarin lessons and is
doing it because I think that anybody
that wants to be part of the future
needs to speak Mandarin and so then that
these are some of the personal lessons
of the sleeve leave you with thanks very
much